CVS Houston affiliate KHOU says a couple  of people who went into an abandoned  home yesterday to smoke pot found a  tiger inside they called authorities who  tranquilized and removed the tiger  officials say it was well fed and in  good shape but it could have broken out  of its loosely secured cage and gone out  and done things that Tigers do an animal  sanctuary will take the tiger to an  undisclosed location today there's no  word on who owned it now going to break  biana you said I hope it wasn't my  parents Oh your parents often go to  abandoned houses looking at smoke pot  hello once I left little mom and dad  golodryga empty nest syndrome now that  would have been a news Hilary that story